ben sei nastri nuovissimo che il play
una nuovissima scriptum eccola lì la
vedete dovremmo scappare da questa
bambina ma l'etica bambola prima bambola
malefica che vi ricordate abbiamo già
giocato un gioco simile cioè le skin
room del fratello di ice cream se non
l'avete visto vi lascio la casellina
finale dopo questo video ma oggi
canteremo da questa epica escape rombo
con questa bambino valenti gatti dei
prossimi mettetevi comodi pre di bob
corn lasciate un bel mi piace e iniziamo
subito eccoci qua
faccio appelli vi piace la mia nuova
pettinatura di più ai miei capelli veri
nella vita reale crescita è vero è
ovviamente sta piovendo e io sono tipo
con
livelli di la strada che sto prendendo
la pizza non ci credo hai trovato il
modo di brenda è per forza
una pizza in mano a lei vediamo dove
dobbiamo andare qua in questa torre
guarda entriamo a
aspetto c'è qualcuno ha perso quasi
baglio
quello era un giocatore che è finita un
po male vedere guarda là dentro siamo
stati dentro perché rimasto lì ok
bisogna stare molto attenti all'orlando
via mentre dalla porta o dalla cor dice
dice di bussare a questa porta o no sono
stato catturato di una rete
anch'io mondo ora finiremo come con lo
scheletro morti qua dentro almeno
abbiamo la pizza potevo mangiare
contentissima perché c'è cibo aspetta
sta succedendo qualcosa togli questa
pizza o non ci vedo niente ma perché
sono io la bianca in mano allora uno
scheletro con un box con un cartone di
pizza in mano
questo era un altro giocatore pietro
quale ed è finito male bisogna stare
sempre attenti c'è una scala qui quanti
a volte si straccerà vitale grava ancora
neanche una volta
wow io adoro l'escape room dentro ai
castelli è una sorta di torre non è
proprio un cappello però le adoro adoro
l'ambientazione specialmente numero uno
non hanno solo pro di voi è andato male
la barra della vita
essere perché quindi vuol dire che è
insomma non muori non ti sfracelli ma
fatti sei più possibilità per a danno di
essermi sfracellato su questo filo
spinato invece no mi sono tolto un po di
percentuale che però potrebbe essere che
se finissi tutta la vita deve
ricominciare di qui la sua vita è
aumentare per questo perché sono
arrivato al check point qua è piena di
trappole
c'è una porta c'è un aborto è diventato
rosso stato
preso preso un importo che ha spaventato
tantissimo
oggi la vedevi stanno rincorrendo cosa
bisogna fare meglio 8 solo ora aspetto
la luce
è sfracellato limite festa beh io non ti
prima cosa bisogna fare allora forse
bisogna farla cadere in una di queste
trappole
open door bisogna tifare elettricità
trasferta ok vediamo se restano credo
prima che mi prendo il problema che
l'eta anche dal senato qualcuno che l'ha
mai alla prima cena e basta vabbè io
devo proseguire su roma
controllando non cadere giù
ma tu sei riuscito a passare su quelle
cose così senza la catena neanche una
volta si
chiamava perché vitale cade sempre la
corsa da bambolina malefica mi ricorda
se avete mai visto i pokémon day come
può dare non averli mai visti che si
ricordano quella prima stagione c'è
sabrina l'allenatrice che aveva una
provino malefica bellissima era ultimi
episodi preferiti beh da evitare sono
quasi rispettando
sopra dobbiamo andare al temine della
sopra vediamo
sì perché siamo in una torre quindi
dobbiamo arrivare in superficie invece
laggiù e dove abbiamo iniziato a
leggere da dove siamo arrivati vedi
quindi se cadiamo judo migliori
cadere o no no io sono riuscito già
passare vediamo cosa ci aspetta adesso
ci sono 30 ci sono delle cose magiche
rosa qui che stanno sparando lombardo le
altre bamboline che carini
molto tenere gli sembrava letali forse
meno
contrita tutto bello ma volevo vedere
bocca ricercato
come detto adesso mi posso vederlo
spesso andava bene il nuovo non ci credo
ok vediamo se lo aspettava da questa
parte vediamo quante altre volte si è
sfracellato vanità no non vogliono più
brava vai in giro ma agricolo per
fortuna ancora non
ha un cappello con cibo
[Musica]
meccanismo non amore si propone altresì
camera l'eti jones che a me fanno
spaventare sempre stiamo arrivando c'è
scritto
che non appare così all'improvviso non
riesco a capire allora dice attento agli
attacchi dall'alto dall'alto quindi lei
comprende cosa che ci ha preso gusto
buonitalia perché non ci abbiamo pensato
prima che proteggono con il pick up
[Musica]
ok allora bisogna fare poco per volta
camminare poi nascondersi sotto ai
funghi
e inquietante i rumori che fa ok
nascondo sotto quest'altro fungo io vi
dirò sentire umori più vuol dire che sta
arrivasse
con funzione andare sotto i funghi aiuto
in tutto
ma tu veux lei non la vedo si sente
solamente ok di abbassare
velocissimamente corriere corridore non
ho detto ok forse ce l'ho fatta da
evitare di gregorio
e figo questo si muove morto ma non
scoppiare per terra e
ogni volta che non i covi fratello io
non è possibile già
fa per la bambola che si chiama miss 30
per milano
[Musica]
si dobbiamo scendere da qui mi sa ok
che c'è qui si scritto caduta forse quel
personaggio con il cibo in testa che
cosa faccia dei calzoni un posto
giu
[Musica]
verifica per primo a prendere il badge
io vitale
hop sospinto anche quell'altro giocatore
simbolo che tutti
facciamo allora ecco cos'era il rumore
degli schiacciatori
il piano piano piano posso fare fatta a
mito serie b
abbracciamo in faccia a faccia con
l'apertura da qua non possiamo saltare
da nessuna parte perché dobbiamo andare
sulle finestre e aspettare che lui passa
no non ci credo sono celato il laser
adesso mi fa povero questo tasto search
e l'ha fatta non ci credo come che è
vitale è diventato così bravo perché
sono troppo forte bravo bravo e qui
hanno visto un attrezzo che ok ora
allora dice di avere il rito di avere
perdere fiducia ok sempre mantenere
aiuto e ora dove dobbiamo andare ad un
non lo so wow
sembra che puoi mettere qualcosa qua
sopra
la pizza o forse
[Musica]
no
forse dobbiamo prendere qualcosa ho
paura che dobbiamo buttarci molto bene
aspettava qua siamo passati non siamo
passati a guardare ecco perché doveva
montare di parte no io non ci posso
credere quante volte visto sbarazzo
dell'ania queste skype roma invece è
vitale no
ci sono dei vari campi gigante che
bisogna stare attenti a non essere
schiacciati da
allora il attento al martello io non ci
posso che cosa sta succedendo sono state
le prove di saltare quando il martello
sale su e poi
tanto ok questa volta ce la faccio
[Musica]
dai ragazzi non so cosa sta succedendo
forse è perché non avete lasciato mi
piace
quindi assai subito un bel mi piace ha
detto che abbiamo le volte fortuna e non
vi straccia è vero che i 10.000
voli rimane lì a talete buttato da solo
mi sono spaventato da quello che ho
visto dopo o no vedo io stessi lo vedo
cos'è un golem non lo sono sempre tipo
una creatura fatta di terra io lo chiamo
era dietro
nomi precisione fronde sì ma riesce a
prendersi anche dalla dietro mi sono
allora tutto bisogna fare
qualcuna è lento magari al cioccolato
da non scartare gli interessi che ce
l'ho fatta come farlo deve continuare a
scappare saltando che ci riprovo che
bello c'è una sfera luminosa bellissima
sicuramente questa che dobbiamo prendere
e portare
non ci credo ci sono riuscito non lo so
come ho fatto ho preso la sfera dai devi
prendere questa sfera e quasi ha scritto
torna da dove sei venuto ok dobbiamo
tornare a
posizionare come l'abbiamo riaffrontare
il golem si è proprio li guarda si sta
aspettando lo vedi
la mia vita sta per finire la vedete
lisi ma adesso c'è anche i bordelli
devono abbassare la guarda come faccio
io l'avevo quando sarà in avanti e per i
fermi quando era madridista del portello
ok dai mica è difficile
sull'ultimo sono scivolato sull'ultimo
ok aspettiamo evitare a proposito di
magie e misteri
grazie mille a tutti voi che avete reso
il mio nuovissimo libro dai e paura
della scuola di mister east e non ce
l'avete ancora non potete non averlo
sono delle storie bellissime che vi
terranno incollati alla fine in cui
potete anche accumulare i punti il
coraggio quindi se ancora non ce l'avete
mi raccomando cliccate nel link
descrittore prendetelo subito allora
vitale dove sei ancora io sono qui mi
ami è sfracellato un paio di volte il
martello ma tu non dice via me che
sapevi benissimo come fare procedeva
saltarlo dei martelli si alzano si si
certo certo però pensavo fosse fosse più
semplice invece no nell'ultima tornata
un paio di volta dai mettiamo subito ok
la sfera è ora attiva
dove sei finito secondo noi non sono
passato per minare io non ti vedo
arrivando con la promozione del sasso la
sua propulsione è viva daremo salendo
dalla bambina malefica duro
dobbiamo salire qua dalle scale presto
studiamo dalle scale e ora
[Musica]
questo che cos'è un bazooka
vuol dire che dovremo affrontare per
anch'io no io preferisco la pizza che
cosa dovremmo affrontare elio l'affronta
son di pizza e siamo in cima alla torre
forse siamo riusciti a raggiungere la
fine allora qui forse bisogna andare
avanti
e se dovessimo sparare a qualcosa per
lavoro
piano wow
mentre non ha funzionato
la gioia della rai ha fatto per l'isis
ragione la piscina vedrà come facevi tu
sì tu no
io sono usciti un po becik altre che ci
cantano prima
forse dobbiamo colpire ma la prima no no
a paurissima e gigante mezzi sono già
morta a tavolino no vabbè dobbiamo
riniziare allora aspetta in due e
difficilissima per fortuna abbiamo un pò
fesso amico con il cappello piatto da
mangiare e qualcun altro
non ti devi buttare da lì devi buttarti
d'acqua tattica di nella piscina e non
ho preso le misure giuste
dai sbrigati dobbiamo affrontare la boxe
[Musica]
forlan
niente mi sto sfracellando c'è anche una
bambolina gigante in testa c'è volevo
dire c'è una bambolina piccola in testa
la bambola gigante quella è la sua vita
la vedete
allora ci sono quasi riuscito a colpirla
quito
ma forse bisogna colpire quella
bambolina gigante la sovra aspetta
aspetta il coordinamento allora è meglio
se tutti e tre proviamo a confine già
perché da soli non ce la faremo mai
crediti aspetto qua in piscina dopo
va di nuovo ai sbagliato asfaltata ho
mancato di poco la piscina ci sono
saltiamo di
allora secondo me se lo facciamo in due
proviamo aspetta era ancora non è cotta
che l'austria se sei colpi ci colpisce
volto
no non ci credo ma come ha fatto a
sconfiggermi già è troppo di forse
bisogna nascondersi dietro hai visto
come
best of oggetti nascosti i cosiddetti
high usa che lancia tipo questi
pipistrelli giganti quindi dobbiamo
aspettare
fate sopra di lanciarli assistito da lei
sta funzionando sta funzionando nascosi
ti nascondi vi è vicinissima dobbiamo
cambiare la squadra dobbiamo cambiare
nascondiglio o no
dài dài colpisci la
no c'è mancato poco vai colpisce la mia
preso
avvicinando
dobbiamo farcela ragazzi dobbiamo
farcela sconfiggerla creativa
[Musica]
o no lucio scappare
non sa dove nascondervi dietro
le trincee
d'aiuto
sono quasi prima capo dai barcelona
scotti no lei sconfitta e le mani ha
sconfitto le c'è uno sconfitto mi ha
sconfitto la farei tra pizzi io abbiamo
perso trambi via becca di questo
maledetto beccati penso che tifare
sabatini maisto
[Musica]
no ma c'ero quasi
ok forse ci siamo ragazzi c'ero quasi
troviamo di nuovo
a giudicare dal sole era un suo
ragionamento quello sta riuscendo da lì
funziona per ora si ok dai dobbiamo fare
anche se si sta bici tanto tantissimo
luca tagliando una vita ma come come
perché chi spara con le cose nere anche
da lontano si sono sbriciolate di nuovo
sì siamo quarti
ci siamo quasi mi manca un corpo da ono
device
[Musica]
ce l'hai fatta ce la fa malissimo
io continua
non ci credo
dai puoi perse la vita anche musica come
si
può dire trovato dietro devo prendere il
nostro pezzo
eccomi presto saltano salviamo
le scappa
lasciato bel mi piace ora vi lasciamo
qualcosa una salina il cane provvedere
tutti gli altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite buona visione